welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Batman video I'll be
talking all about Batman Beyond the
original movie in the new one that
they're talking about doing with Michael
Keaton's character there have even been
some reports about Warner Brothers plans
for their backup Batman should Michael
Keaton decide to back out of the project
before they're able to make the flash
movie so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with Michael Keaton's Batman in a Batman
Beyond movie so you're starting with
number 5 if you missed the news the last
week or you're not sure why everyone is
suddenly posting Batman Beyond all over
the place and Michael Keaton pictures
it's because the whole idea of bringing
Michael Keaton back is a much older
version of his 1989 Tim Burton Batman is
for him to be a mentor to the younger
characters now short term that's the DC
EU Justice League characters like the
flash so he's not replacing the Ben
Affleck Batman they're not retconning
him or anything like that he's a Batman
from the multiverse the websites that
were reporting this last week like the
rap deadline variety Hollywood Reporter
didn't really clarify some of those
details so a lot of people were confused
about how they're going to handle this
the whole idea is that he would be a
Batman from the multiverse from his Tim
Burton 1989 film we'll call it the
Burton verse and because the flash
character is all about the multiverse
and completely messing with a timeline
he does something that puts him line of
sight with Michael Keaton's Batman like
accidentally phasing to his earth and
winding up in his Batcave then he gets
his help with the events of the movie we
don't know the entire plot of the film
because it's gonna be a different
version than the comic book flashpoint
but you can theorycraft about that all
you want in the comments the way we get
to Batman Beyond is because they said
that Keaton is coming back for multiple
films multiple crossovers some of them
oba cameos some of them would be bigger
roles down the road and obviously when
you talk about older versions of Batman
mentoring younger characters that is
literally the story of Batman Beyond
he's just the flash flashpoint movie is
the first movie that he would appear in
and they're gonna start filming that
early next year so number four the news
reports didn't list every single movie
that Warner Brothers
wants to put his older Batman in except
for the Batgirl movie almost everybody
mentioned this which apparently they're
still planning on making he would be a
mentor to a version of a Barbara Gordon
Batgirl but because she's not a
character who spends a lot of time
traveling the multiverse her stories are
more like straight-up Batman stories
noir detective thrillers adventure
serials they haven't really clarified
where her Batgirl would come from where
it would be set in the timeline and how
that's going to work because I don't
think they're gonna spend a lot of time
de-aging Keaton's Batman unless it's for
flashbacks to explain what he's been
doing since the events of Batman Returns
recently on kevin smith's podcast Hina's
co-hosts were talking about the
possibility of the Batgirl movie being a
version of a Batman Beyond story I think
that was mostly them talking about him
mentoring a younger version of a bat
family character but it wouldn't be
Batgirl taking Terry mcginnises place
she wouldn't be wearing the Batman
Beyond bat suit and the movie would
still be called Batgirl this will make a
little more sense when you consider what
the overarching plan for the Batman IP
is Warner Brothers because you have a
lot of different versions of Batman
flying around now during that podcast
they also mentioned that part of the
idea is the new Keaton's storyline well
somewhat retcon some of the events of
Batman Forever and Batman and Robin the
Schumacher films maybe not completely
but since Michael Keaton left after
Batman Returns and now he's coming back
it just makes his timeline a lot simpler
and a lot easier to follow if they say
that the Schumacher Batman films took
place in another universe so they're not
totally retconning everything remember
this is the multiverse so it all
happened just some of it happened in
another universe it's not that big a
deal it just depends on how connected
you think that those sequels were to
Keaton's Batman films because Michael
Goff's
Alfred was the one who stayed on for all
those so he kind of connects those films
but I think it's easier to say that
those just took place in alternate
universes so number three the actual
idea is that eventually they get Keaton
to do a full-blown live-action Batman
Beyond movie down the road and it would
be a straight up telling of the comic
book story a young Terry McGinnis
discovers the Batcave learns Bruce
Wayne's secret after he's too old and
physically broken to wear the suit
effectively in the movie takes place in
the present day of the Tim Burton Batman
universe then under the guise of working
for Bruce Wayne as his assistant just
takes them
mantle of the bat and wears the suit
while old Bruce Wayne Keaton's Batman
sits in the Batcave calling the shots
and teaching him the ways of the force
but in terms of timing it doesn't sound
like they plan on making either that
Batgirl movie or the Batman Beyond movie
until Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson
the Batman trilogy has already released
at least one of the sequels everyone
went so crazy when Keaton was announced
last week that I think the Batman 2021
movie kind of got lost in all the news
like how are they gonna handle all these
different versions of Batman which one
is the main version a couple days after
the Keaton Batman news broke there were
a couple follow-up reports that said
that the grand plan for the Batman IP is
that the studio is considering Robert
Pattinson is the main version of Batman
so to speak the Batman movie with Matt
Reeves is their big crown jewel
franchise where most of their attention
is going so he's gonna get most of the
limelight for the next couple of years
while they gives us that new Batman
trilogy all the Michael Keaton Batman
cameos and crossovers during that same
time are just meant to be the icing on
the cake like really really cool deep
cut Easter eggs that broaden the DC
movie universe in the multiverse in
really cool ways
so think about Tom Welling during crisis
on Infinite Earths everybody heard that
his Superman was coming back but we
didn't know what they were gonna do with
the character he was really only on
screen for a little while so I'm
thinking that's gonna be a little bit
the way they treat the Keaton Batman
character in some of his upcoming movies
like he'll do some really cool stuff but
he's not gonna be on screen for quite as
much as people expect him to be in
number - speaking of which next cool
Batman Easter Egg is recently and some
of those same reporters from last week
have been talking about the version of
the Batsuit that Keaton's Batman would
have in present day during the flash
flashpoint movie no one seems to know
whether or not he's actually going to be
wearing it but all the reports are
saying that he'll have a modified
version of a Kingdom Come Batman suit
with the exoskeleton that helps him walk
quinoa's said that he never liked the
rubber bat suits that he wore back
during his days as Batman so I think
Warner Brothers is trying to find a way
for him to be Batman and even show up in
a Batman costume without actually having
to put on a physical Batman costume in
that is exactly how Robert Downey jr.
becomes Iron Man in the newer Marvel
movies most of the time he doesn't wear
the suit at all on screen he'll do it
some camera references every once in a
while but most of the time he just walks
around with dots on him and they'll put
the Iron Man suit on him in
post-production so imagine a fully CG
version of a Kingdom Come Batman suit on
Keaton during this flashpoint movie they
kind of did a practical version of that
with Kevin Conroy's Batman during crisis
on Infinite Earths he was a version of a
Batman Beyond Batman but also Kingdom
Come with the harness they even did a
special feature read of him talking
about the suit and coming back it was
actually really cool because it was
Kevin Conroy finally doing live-action
Batman the point of this exoskeleton is
to support his body because he's been so
beaten and broken that he would not be
able to stand up without it and then
they turn it on no I never thought I'd
get a chance to do it on camera because
I was getting older and older and older
I was sort of aging out of Batman you
know but luckily I aged into over his
weight as cool as that was just to be
clear Keaton's old Batman would probably
be very different from crisis on
Infinite Earths Batman I don't think
they're gonna go that dark with Keaton's
Batman
it was revealed during that episode that
crisis Batman had killed all of his
major villains and kept trophies from
his kills and had also killed his
version of Superman just crazy dark
story but number one taking things back
to the original Batman Beyond movie so
if you haven't watched that in a while
it's basically the return of the Joker
because the Joker within the context of
that series died a long time ago or
seemingly died it was revealed that
before he died though he joke arises Tim
Drake implants a chip in his brain that
allows him to take over his
consciousness in the distant future
effectively allowing the Joker to come
back to life in the future timeline of
Batman Beyond but if you've never read
any of those Batman Beyond stories
there's an ongoing comic book most of
the modern Batman films in the comics
are represented in some futuristic
iteration an adult Damian Wayne is still
alive he eventually becomes the new
demons head after racial ghoul perma
dies and gets super pissed when he finds
out that Terry McGinnis has taken the
mantle of the bat from his father he and
Bruce Wayne are estranged they haven't
talked to each other in years the older
version of Dick Grayson Nightwing has
moved back to blüdhaven he's still
trying to do what he can there Barbara
Gordon is now
the new police commissioner just like
her father and for the most part it
feels like a Batman movie done as if it
were a Blade Runner movie so when you're
thinking about the look in the feel of a
live-action Batman Beyond movie just
think the Blade Runner movies and
apparently right now the rumor that's
going around is that Warner Brothers
contingency for their other backup
Batman if Michael Keaton chooses to back
out before they make the project is
actually going to Christian Bale to get
him to come back as an older Batman
obviously he's not quite as old as
Keaton's Batman and I don't know if they
would also try to get him to come back
for a live-action Batman Beyond because
he's not quite old enough for that so
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you also think about the idea of
then trying to get Christian Bale's
Batman to come back he said that he'd
never come back he says that he was kind
of done with the Batman character even
though there was a brief period where he
said that he and Christopher Nolan
almost did a fourth Batman movie but the
reason why he left was because
Christopher Nolan was the first person
to say that he didn't want to do another
Batman movie
that's when Christian Bale also backed
out there'll be a whole bunch of Batman
news at this big DC fan dome Comic Con
panel happening this summer mostly for
the Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves
Batman movie but I'll do as many videos
as I can for all that stuff leave all
your requests in the comments below to
every one click here for my new Michael
Keaton Batman video and click here for
that new trailer for the boys season 2
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you